i've seen all of the keys
which will be made available um to us
um with the emerging integrated care
leadership arrangements and are within
that particular budget envelope
um
so i think the only other thing i wanted
to say was that the arrangements
proposed in relation to the place based
leader represent a holding position for
trafford um and this is due to the fact
the arrangements for health and care
integration are still emerging still
under development both nationally and
also within greater manchester we are
getting clarity
um in terms of functions to be delegated
at local level and what will
need to be
delivered at a greater manchester and a
system level
um and the trafford locality board has
agreed that the place-based leader
arrangement should be reviewed in light
of that emerging in position
and the the will be considered further
by the board in december
so um just for the the note the
committee and council will therefore
note that the arrangements are to the
extent of an interim temporary nature
and a further report will be brought to
both this committee and to council
setting out the position um following
that period so
getting to the
recommendations now so in summary
this this committee is asked to
note
the proposed changes and comment on or
comment on the proposed changes to the
job description and the role profile of
the chief executive
to incorporate the duties of the
place-based lead for health and care
integration arising by virtual virtue of
the proposals for integration of health
and social care
pursuant to the health and care act 2022
recommend that council approves a
revised salary for the chief executive
of 182081
in recognition of the extension of the
duties and responsibilities which will
be covered by her in that role
recommend that council approve the
salary level of 145 145 per annum for
the corporate director of strategy and
resources in recognition of the
additional duties arising by virtual
decision that she should continue to act
as the deputy chief executive
and to note that we will be looking to
appoint a senior delivery lead to
support the chief executive in the
place-based lead role in the delivery of
the nhs functions
who is proposed to be jointly
accountable to the integrated care board
and the chief executive
and as i say to note that the proposed
arrangements are a holding position
while the governance arrangements for
integration continue to evolve and be
clarified
and that we will
take further report to this committee
and to and or to council
following that
period
thank you
thanks angela does anybody have any
questions go aiden thank you
um thank you chair um i i was going to
ask a question about whether or not this
was going to be a permanent arrangement
but i think that's been clarified that
this is a holding
position the reason i think it's
important to look at that i'm happy to
support the recommendations i know it's
we're only noting them this evening and
but i would just express my own
reservations that ideally i i don't
particularly like this arrangement um in
terms of sort of
seconding the chief executive i think
you know
as trafford council
um we want a chief executive whose sole
concern and work is invested in the
operations of trafford council um but i
i understand how we've how we've gotten
to the place where that we are and and i
recognize that this is an arrangement
that most gm authorities i think are
also um pursuing um
so for that reason and i'm really
pleased to note that it's a holding
position can you clarify that in
december 2022 because it just strikes me
that um
that that piece of work around
integration is going to be absolutely
huge um and actually december 22 is not
really a particularly long time away
yeah in answer to question i can confirm
that the review is um
[Music]
the dead the date is is december 2022
and i think by then we will have
transferred the ccgs into the integrated
care system and i think will be a lot
clearer on how the governance the scheme
of reservation delegation will work
and we'll know
how the as i say the governance
arrangements will support the the you
know the design of of the roles that we
have we absolutely need to provide
capacity to the chief executive and to
trafford this from a sort of health and
care system
um so yeah it is december 2022. and
could that be the possibility that we
see sort of an extension of the holding
position so perhaps you know a further
six months were added onto that
arrangement i think i think absolutely i
think we we've come up with a
six month holding position but we do
need to as i say do do that work do that
assessment um and then you know in six
months time we're in a transitional year
i think um and i think we will we'll
take a view as we get more um
clarification yeah
and and the only other thing i was going
to say was that i'm i'm for those the
reasons i've sort of touched on i'm
supportive of the recommendation in
respect to the depth of chief executive
as well um i i think that's really
welcome given um the chief executive's
time is going to be
partially invested in in other
adventures now um
the only other thing i sort of wanted to
reflect on is that there are some
implications i think for this
arrangement that maybe could have been
slightly more drawn out in the report
i'm just looking at the implications
overview on pages one and two there are
risks i think that you know when you
lose senior officer capacity there's
implications for service delivery
service continuity so um but
having said that i think we've drawn
that out in the discussion in the
presentation so i
thank that and that's what i really want
to say thank you
thanks i agree councillor williams we're
not the report doesn't tell us how much
of the chief executive's time will be
devoted in these initial months whether
that will tail off as the system gets
embedded so that's something we would
like to be kept aware of once the
position's a lot clearer
thank you
yeah i mean i'm i'm very supportive of
the
report and the proposals i think it is
massive to integrate health and social
care there's no question about that
um
i slightly disagree
with aiden um
with regard to
uh having that
um
role within the chief executive because
i think it's
absolutely central really in in terms of
what we're going to be doing in the next
i say you know probably five years in
the way that this this will develop and
uh if you've got someone in that
absolute leadership within the council
and the authority then i think that you
know helps to actually
progress what we're trying to do
with with
health and social care so
i'm very supportive of the report i
think it's right to
have reviews
you know um at the end of the year um
and just to see how things are going and
um you know what are the next steps
really
well i think
it's always been a priority of ours that
we do something to address the very real
health inequalities that exist in
trafford and this might be a way that
we're able to impact much more so we'll
be very interested in what comes forward
angela thank you
so go ahead counselor boys
thank you chair yeah i'm obviously i'm
i'm clearly generally in support of of
the report in the nature of uh these
changing roles for the time being um
having been
involved a little bit back in us
hsm days and howard bernstein talking
about the whole business of
of integrating health and social care
moving on to the thing that actually
does concern me a little bit because it
might seem a little simple is that
actually in the job description of the
chief executive i just find it very
difficult to believe that nine of these
things are actually
accessible by tested at an assessment
center i think there's some of them that
you just can't assess there and there's
two or three in particular you can
assess them by application you can
assess them at interview but there's no
way in an assessment center that you can
actually test so i think there's one or
two things in that
a little bit over the top in believing
that you're going to
in the future assess people
as an assessment center for um
their success of leading motivating
teams of senior staff at level you can't
do that an assessment centre it just
doesn't happen so that's my comments
really and probably having had an
experience of a few of these things
but basically
back to the report totally in favor of
it thank you chair thank you councillor
boys
any further comments or any further
questions for angelo
okay thank you i've not been informed of
any urgent business so
if we i think that finishes the meeting
and thank you all for your time
thank you thank you chair for your
chairmanship during the year thank you
thank you everybody